well explosions have been heard in
southern Lebanon as bombardments
continue between Israel and Hezbollah up
to 60,000 people have already been
displaced on the Lebanese side since the
fighting began with thousands more
evacuated from their homes on the
Israeli side too let's speak to Ali
hasham he is in nakura in southern
Lebanon for us Ali what have you been
hearing there from the
border well uh with the number of U
displaced people increasing there
there's possibility that there will be
more especially with the fires on the
border between Lebanon and Israel
especially towards the area where we are
here in nakura and also another town to
to the South from here which is Al both
are on the border but the other one is
after here anyway uh we've been there
and actually maybe ra can show us a bit
of the smoke here most of the bushes
around nakura and Al are right now
Ablaze following Israeli bombing with
uh phosphorus white phosphorus bombs
every now and then we can hear
explosions coming from these areas these
are cluster bombs this area has a um
Legacy with cluster bombs from the 2006
war between hisbah and Israel and of
course now so uh the municipality in
nakura is now calling on the United
Nations here in Lebanon and uh nakura is
the headquarters of the United Nations
to try help in uh extinguishing the fire
also Civil Defense Forces are trying
there are a lot of attempts but the
infrastructure doesn't really exist
there are no helicopters there no
Advanced ways to um to try contain the
fire so this is this is the situation
and there are a bit of concerns that
these fires especially that in the town
of almash the fire came close to
residential areas especially houses on
the peripheries in nakura it's still a
bit far but there are a lot of concerns
that the fire will will get into the the
town if if things aren't done to to stop
it somewhere I'm sure Ali hasham there
with the latest forest from nakura in
southern Lebanon near the Israeli border
thank you Ali well let's now bring in
Tam kamut he's a professor of public
policy at the Doha Institute for
Graduate Studies Tam I know we keep
talking about the the fears of a
potential escalation and Hezbollah has
been very careful so far but will they
continue with that as the death toll
continues to mount in Gaza uh anasia
that's a very good and difficult
question my guess that yes it will be it
will continue to be a calculated
response so the more the situation gets
uh serious in the Gaza Strip it's
already very serious but let's hasah was
very clear about setting a red line
which is land Invasion so they
threatened that if a land
Invasion uh starts that they will be
they might join this uh this round of of
War so uh let's see so far what they're
doing is they're keeping the northern
front uh busy active they're engaging
with Israel and uh and it's more or less
a calculated response so they want more
or less to divert the military also
attention of Israel and to keep the
northern front alive to um to release
some remove some pressure from from from
Gaza but it's still very small when it
comes to scale to the scale of the
operations and uh and and the
disengagement so it's still small but
given how imminent the Israelis keep
saying this ground invasion is I mean if
that does actually take place that's
essentially calling Hezbollah
Bluff yeah I mean so so so let's put
things into perspective so hisbah is a
is in a really delicate situation so
it's between two pressures first it is
of course hasbalah is is is part of this
resistance since AIS Hamas and Iran also
but at the same time Lebanon is in a
very dire political and social economic
conditions and
so's military political Doctrine has
always been that we are there to protect
Lebanon to and also to fight Israel okay
uh now if it does not let's say if the
if if a ground Invasion happens in the
Gaza Strip and they don't launch a full
war on Israel from their side so its
political legitimacy will be eroded
inside Lebanon but at the same time a
large portion of the lebanes society
also they don't want war as well because
they are already in their situation so
hisbah has to delicately balance between
these two pressures and they are not in
an easy position by any mean and also we
have to look at the Iranian Factor as
well will Iran support hisbah if it
decides to go into a full war with
Israel or not because you need also an
strategic depth correct like you need I
mean if a war happens with
hisbah then we're talking about military
supplies Logistics as well so you will
expect a role from Iran as well so all
these things are being calculated more
or less but it's still it's it's it's
it's a vague situation we don't know
what's well we still can't really have
this conversation without talking about
the United States as well and they've
been saying that well it's reported that
they've been saying they want this
ground Invasion delayed ostensibly
because they also want to get some
assets into the region and Safeguard
their own troops and and their own
assets there is it just that or is the
US actually now rethinking its whole
approach to this
conflict another difficult question but
let me let me put it this way so uh I
think the Americans are there to
shoulder the Israelis in these difficult
times for the Israelis and also to offer
military assistance and and and of
course uh don't forget I mean and say
the US has vast experience in
Afghanistan
Iraq fua mul so they have been involved
or they were like you know involved in
such Wars like you know Urban Wars like
in the Gaza and they have advises on the
ground exactly so and the Israelis I'm
sure they need all kind of expertise and
assistance on board so my guess uh and
also following the Israeli media and
political positions there has to be a
land Invasion to satisfy Israel's
Grievances and also to set a new
standard of deterrence like you know
after this Mega like you know event that
happened so uh the US is there I think
to shoulder the Israelis to offer them
help and assistance and also to make
sure to control the Israelis that they
don't do any
impulsive make they don't make any
impulsive decisions that need that lead
to a further escalation I mean Netanyahu
is unexpected his behavior is unexpected
like you know he I mean so a scenario
that involves a war with Iran natalu
taking the opportunity now having all
this us support to like Iran for example
the nuclear facilities you never know so
they want to make sure so that they're
restraining Israel's response and
Israel's and make sure they don't go in
any any impulsive behavior or
uncalculated decisions so I think more
or less this is the US rule into the
entire uh game like you know an attempt
at containment it sounds like more or
less yes Tamar kamut um from the Doha
Institute of Graduate Studies thank you
for joining me again here in Doha my
pleasure